support from the big trade union this is
of course key to Jeremy caught wind with
me now is the leader of unite lemma
classic one of the biggest unions do you
think the Labour Party is ready to fight
and win an early general election in the
next 12 months
yes something I do I think it's been a
good week I think we've seen the
reelection of Jeremy and/or the
landslide victory I think we've seen
some excellent contributions in
particular from the front bench
spokesmen and of course the challenge
now for Jeremy and his team is to try
and unite the party and begin to develop
a cohesive alternative strategy to the
current government so that we can
address people's fears and put to them a
program that will inspire them well
let's take the issues that are of
concern to people we know that a
majority voted for brexit we also know
that worries about migration and
immigration played a big part in that
easy it a good idea for the leaders to
say he's not bothered about numbers he
doesn't want to do anything well I
haven't heard him say that Adam
obviously he'll it's in the newspapers
as well as we briefed it involved he'll
address that in his speech so we'll have
to wait to see but of course the
question of the free movement of labour
is something that the Labour Party
invades the conservative governments
have to deal with it is an issue it's an
issue that is a concern to a number of
people and Jeremy himself has already
talked in terms about greater collective
bargaining because what's happening with
migrant labour it produces a cheap pool
of labor which greedy bosses use to
drive down wages if we had collective
bargaining again in sectors then that
wouldn't happen but if you allow
unlimited free movement that is simply
going to continue isn't it well are
those extra people are going to be able
to leave the question of free movements
of labour is an issue not only in the UK
but in Europe nobody ever talks about
the countries where the migrant workers
are coming from being denuded of the
skilled labour that is needed to bring
their economies yeah but I mean it
sounds like you're saying you think that
do need to be some kind of risk
Shinzon people coming in which is
contrary to jeremy corbyn's position i
believe that there should be an the
issue of free movement of labour means
challenging the only person i've had put
forward a solution to it is jeremy
corbyn free collective bargaining and
proper collective sexual targeting will
actually reduce the amounts of cheap
labour what you're saying that if you
had the proper controls on the market
you wouldn't need to control the basic
question of people from Romania or
Poland I think it would be less of an
issue less of a problem I mean just
recently Romanian nurses were given a
50% pay rise to stop them leaving their
country the reality is that if we can
control terms and conditions and pay
properly in this country then the issue
wouldn't be that's not what mr. gorban
is saying today I mean he's saying he
wants additional funding to help
refugees come here but he doesn't want
to impose a limit and I'm also saying of
your members as they want restriction
he's also saying that he wants to
provide additional money in those areas
where migrant workers are coming to
important pressure on the social
services so that's a plus that this
government abolished what about the ban
on fracking that the Corbin government
proposes were you consulted on that in
advance I mean that's going to affect
your members well my my unions policy is
to oppose fracking simply terrestrial
but fracking so of course you do have
members in the industry well we have of
course we do and we have to kind of deal
with that in a manner that responds to
their concerns as well this issue of
fracking is a major debate taking place
and so what we are hoping for is that
the debate will unfold and the issues
surrounding the dangers of fracking will
become more transparent I'm really
driving it is is you know we know the
unions are very important part of the
labor movement you founded the party we
know that you have instinctive
enthusiasm for some of the things that
mr. Corbett's been saying well I just
wonder if you're being consulted about
the nitty-gritty because in the end this
is about how it offends your your
members in your work I'm the most
important thing and
exciting thing for me is that we have a
Labour leadership who were genuinely
interested in an industrial strategy
investing in manufacturing that's the
key to everything
proper decent jobs sustainable growth
that is what our people that's what my
members want and this Labour leadership
is the first to take it seriously I'm
delighted that Theresa May is put
industrial strategy on the business plan
knowing the name placing weight off but
what does it actually mean because the
Tories haven't had an industrial
strategy for a long long but if it means
higher corporation tax higher taxes
overall that's going to drag down
businesses little bit for Adam is the
opposite it's about a British investment
bank it's about Regional Development
then every way you're gonna get that
money but it's going to be from Tyson
their businesses exist so it's it's a
simpler you some might say it's simple
Kings you know logic that if you can
generate a demand within the economy for
example thirty years ago sixty five
percent of the wealth that we created
went into the back pockets of workers
that's now down to 53 Pepperberg percent
economists will tell you that that's
disastrous for sustainable growth what
jeremy corbyn and can i say this what
businesses all blue chip companies that
i deal with what they are desperate for
is investment and a government strategy
Corbin's going to give them that what
about party unity I mean you've been one
of the strongest critics and Blair
writes as you like to call them would
you like to see some of the post Blair
rights now taking a front rank role
within the shadow cabinet oh I think
it's I think it's right now that the
party should come together and I think
it will we already know there's a number
of MPs have said they want to come back
to the Shadow Cabinet so of course I
would encourage me did you did you agree
with that speech from Tom Watson
yesterday that's what's on the speech
was extraordinary it confused me it
seemed to be saying that New Labour and
the third wave was the way forward again
now it just surprised me Adam because
Jeremy Corbyn and John McDonough later
putting forward an alternative the right
wing of the party have got known for
what it was so they're going back to yes
tea
what I was saying was that the Blair
government was and the brown government
were successful government's growth
throughout that period and that you had
to work with business and private
enterprise where could business and
Providence about what he was saying I'll
tell you what there was no vision it was
yesteryear during the Blair years and of
course they did lots of good things but
we still lost 1 million manufacturing
jobs the gap between rich and poor
continued the seeds of inequality that
were suffering today were watered and
sown there so Tom speech was you know
extraordinary it did nothing to me in
terms of telling us a vision going
forward and the politics of yesteryear
time for a new deputy leader
well if Tom wants to try and refresh his
Monday he could be interested to see
what happens